hello there today we're going to look at
ext5 towards extreme multi-task scaling
for transfer learning by researchers of
google research and deepmind this paper
introduces two new things the first
thing is this ex mix which stands for
extreme mixture this is a data set it's
actually a collection they say a massive
collection of 107 supervised nlp tasks
across diverse domains and task families
so this is a big collection of tasks and
using that collection they train this
new model
ext5 which as you can guess is a t5
model trained on this ex mix data set or
pre-trained on this ex t5 data set and
by doing that they can show that this
model once you fine tune it on the
downstream tasks achieves much better
performance than if you were to
pre-train with less tasks or just
something like language modeling in fact
the final model they come up with is a
mix of the language model
self-supervised pre-training task and
training on these 107 supervised tasks
all at the same time
and that seems to be a strong model it
outperforms they say
strong t5 baselines on super glue and a
bunch of other tasks
some tasks which are inside of the
training set so some tasks are going to
be part of those 107 tasks but some
aren't and even on those tasks the model
drastically improves over other
models such as t5 so we're going to look
at
what the data set here how it is
constructed and i like the way they
approach
this right here and the kind of ablation
experiments they do to show
that
really the the scale of or the amount of
tasks and the diversity of tasks is what
really makes the difference right here
at least they give some good evidence
for that hypothesis it could still be
that the selection is important
but you'll see
yeah that's that's the overview let's
dive into it so what is t5
t5 is this model this idea that we can
solve any nlp task with essentially the
same model so a tfm a t5 model is a
language model the language model gets a
few tokens as an input and this asks to
complete
the sequence or to continue the sequence
this is a standard language model right
if you have a sentence starting here you
can ask the model to complete the
sentence
however
there are other tasks such other tasks
than language modeling in nlp there is
for example
question answering
now in question answering you want to
come up with an answer maybe the answer
is part of the document so this is your
document right and you want to come up
with an answer to a question
that is answered in the document and you
would point out here is the answer right
that is what you would do if you were to
do something like bert like a bird model
you'd put on top here you would feed all
the sequence in and then the model would
output
for these tokens this is the answer not
with t5 with t5 what you would do is you
would ask the model in a language
modeling way to continue here and give
you the answer essentially give you
these tokens
so everything is formulated as a
language modeling task and this is done
by using clever prompting so here you
can see a list of these tasks this is
the same for t5 and ext5 the difference
be of between them is that ext5 is
pre-trained on a much larger set of such
tasks so for example
if
the
task is question answering the input is
this right here as you can see it says
question
colon right and this here that's kind of
the
the pre-prompt this question colon that
that's sort of prompting the model to
now do question answering
what does the sun represent on the you
on the uruguay flag and the answer is
the may revolution of 1810
um
here is some some other
i guess this is what dialogue modeling
person one so true story i once swam
with monterrey was awesome person two
colon right you see this format this
person one colon person two colon this
is how they represent dialogue modeling
so you don't have to build a separate
model for each task you simply have to
find a way to formulate the task in a
language modeling way such that you can
indicate to the model what kind of task
it is by using a prompt structure
and then the model will
sort of recognize what this is you may
have seen right you may have seen this
in gpt3 now the difference is
in gpt3 you can do prompts like this and
you probably will get an answer here
that fits to person 2.
the difference is gpt 3
during training time has also has only
done language modeling nothing else but
language modeling
while
and then it simply has picked up these
patterns as it went along sort of
learning from what was scraped from the
internet however
uh t5 here is explicitly trained on
these tasks so prompts like these will
actually be part of the training set
now it doesn't mean that
um
so you can do then two things once you
train such a model you can evaluate it
on tasks that have been in the training
set be that on the evaluation sets of
the respective tasks but they would
still be considered sort of in
distribution tasks so you've explicitly
trained the model for these tasks or you
can test it on out of distribution tasks
which is here would be a task like a
different task but you haven't trained
on that task but you use the trained
model to evaluate on it this comes much
closer to something like gpt3 right you
have done supervised pre-training here
but the supervision was on a way
different task than what you evaluate so
we're going to see these two different
things so that's the idea of t5
you they pair this here with language
modeling
so
uh there is this one pre-training task
right here that as you can see masks out
a bunch of parts of a piece of text and
then the model is asked to reconstruct
it again it's asked to reconstruct it in
a language modeling way so this whole
thing would be your prompt with these
special mask tokens and then this whole
piece of text right here would be the
output and you would train the model to
produce that output right something like
gpt3 is probably not going to produce
the output in a structured way where it
says well mask 0 and then mask 1 and so
on
so those are the mixture it's a 107
107 supervised tasks and then this here
i think comes from common crawl from c4
uh you just do self-supervised training
on top of that and you mix all of that
together during training and then you
have apparently a super powerful model
that if you take it and you fine tune it
on a downstream task it is going to
perform quite well
that's essentially the whole model it is
not conceptually different from t5 it's
simply this fact that we now have the
107 tasks so they have a split up of
what the 107 tasks are but mostly they
fall into kind of different categories
here they have these task families
there's summarization dialogue modeling
natural language inference so
classification semantic parsing
common sense
closed book question answering and
reading comprehension so this is this is
quite uh
quite a different selection of tasks you
can see that there's uh wide like dialog
modeling might require some real world
sort of knowledge to be in there you can
see wizards of wikipedia is in that data
set but also there is something like
semantic parsing so you've already seen
uh funk ql
up here so here is this is the input
parse to funcul
give me a list of airlines in pittsburgh
it would actually
transfer or translate this prompt this
natural language input to a funk ql or
funcl i don't even know how to how to
say that
output you can see the tasks are quite
diverse but in all of them you have to
sort of do something with the language
right beyond just language modeling
right so they they now do a bunch of
different experiments um and the
first experiment is with respect to
these these task families they wonder
they wonder
does it help or kind of hurt if we
include a dialogue task for another
dialogue task if we include an nli task
for a dialogue task and so on they want
to understand how do these tasks sort of
fit together do they help each other do
they hurt each other or you know what's
going on and for that they so in this
here they have like some inter intra
family correlations and turns out most
tasks in the same family actually help
each other though not all
which is weird but
uh the families are of course something
arbitrary that the author simply laid on
top of the of these 107 different tasks
right so it's not necessarily the case
that all the
within family tasks are necessarily so
similar to each other
um
though the authors say that there are
some of the 107 that fit no category so
the categories here are simply for
evaluating some measures of how the
tasks help each other
so now what they do is they as if i
understand this correctly they take a
pre-trained um
model
presumably a t5 model if i understand
this correctly so they take it
not maybe not a t5 um
i don't actually
i don't actually have this present in my
mind um
however
they take some model that has been
pre-trained on something maybe not
pre-trained at all
and they fine-tune it
on two tasks at the same time so rather
than fine-tuning it on one task they
fine-tune it on two tasks or
respectively here
rather than fine-tuning it on one task
family
such as the nli family they fine tune it
on two together
okay so um
here you can like this cell right here
is what if i
fine tune
on nli tasks and on cls tasks
together okay
and
i fine tune on them together and then i
evaluate
on the column so row i've column j i
evaluate the performance on family j so
i
fine tune on classification and nli
together and then i look at the
performance on nli on the on the test
sets of these tasks right and my
question is
is that more or less than if i were to
just fine tune on nli which is this
diagonal entry right here i fine tune on
nli and nli given like the same compute
budget select one of these two numbers
one it's sort of the data equivalent to
both tasks and one is the compute
equivalent
you can choose but given that this cell
is green right here i think the authors
have taken have chosen the top number to
be sort of the more representative one
in this case you see that
training
swift
sorry
co-training classification tasks and nli
tasks
benefits
nli task evaluation
compared to just
fine tuning on nli tasks okay that's how
you read these
these numbers
or
maybe i'm wrong but that's how i think
you read these numbers
so on the other hand
you look for example right here
you have
ha this c m n s i don't actually
remember what that family
the name is it gets a performance of
68.24
if it's just trained by itself if it's
fine-tuned by itself if you add
the cbqa
family
it gains in perfect wait a minute
it is green
column
[Music]
j column j
this is a column right
could this be could this be actually rho
no this is smaller than this why is this
green
why is it green
i'm
i'm confused
um
maybe they have to compare with the
average right here
i'm confused by this table
i i thought it meant i thought it meant
if you co-train on the two actually it
gets better however the 66 is clearly
smaller than the 68
so
maybe they consider the row
not the column
i don't know
no they do consider the column because
they in the text they say
look for example adding an nli task you
can see in the row this is whatever
happens to another task if you add the
nli tasks this is very often beneficial
right you can see right here it's very
often a good thing to add the nli task
for example but then on the other hand
the summarization task
it's often very negative if you add a
summarization task
so it's not the result from this
experiment at least they say
is that it is not
clear whether or not adding more or
fine-tuning on multiple tasks together
helps or hurts ultimately right so that
is
already very special recognition this is
not yet pre-training
but it is something about training
multiple tasks together it doesn't
always seem to help for the end result
okay so i think i figured it out um yeah
i think they do in fact compare to the
lower row right here and this row is the
average without
regarding the diagonal so this is on
average how does a given task fare when
you add other tasks or other task
families and then they evaluate whether
there is a significant deviation you
know to the to the top or to the bottom
with the red and green numbers
so mystery solved yay
i think the lesson from this is that it
is not entirely clear that
co-training helps here
and
now what they do is they go and they say
okay
can we figure out like we have 107 tasks
and we set ourselves one goal which is
super glue which is one of the
one of the common benchmarks in nlp i
think it itself
consists of i believe 11 sub tasks or
something like this and is is most
commonly reported in these nlp papers
that do multiple tasks so
super glue is the benchmark can we find
a subset of these 107 tasks that
when we pre-train
on when we pre-trained on
these tasks and then fine tune on super
glue it's going to be very very good
um on super glue right because given
from this table it's not entirely clear
that we should include all of the tasks
because they sometimes might hurt each
other
so now we're going to try to say can we
find a subset that is just really good
for the super glue downstream task
and what the authors do is they do
different things so vanilla i believe is
you pre-train on zero tasks you just
train on super glue okay cool
um and then this this
random 55 is simply 55 random tasks now
why 55 i don't know it might be because
it's kind of half of what they have or
because it
very narrowly beats
whatever they have here the best effort
the best effort is the author saying
okay let's look at super glue
um
i'm not exactly even sure
what
so let's look at super glue and let's
look at all
of the sort of helpful families right
here
they say
specifically we include nli common sense
classification and closed book qa tasks
from the ex mix to form a mixture of 48
tasks to include in a multi-task
pre-training setup so you can see those
are the tasks right here if i see this
correctly
these four tasks that all have the green
numbers right here so in on average
these task families help other tasks
and as you can see
with this is 48 tasks that were selected
after extensive evaluation and simply by
picking random 55 random tasks you're
already better in the downstream
performance on superglue
keep in mind this table here is
co-fine-tuning or co-training on two
tasks and then evaluating on one of them
which is different than pre-training on
a task and then fine-tuning and
evaluating on another one but still it
is sort of an effort by the authors to
say you know
what what could we do right here
and
yeah as you can see
the final result obviously is that if
you use all 107 tasks you get way better
results so it seems to be
this is a good indication that is really
about the scale and diversity and might
not matter too much that you have this
huge task overlap
although it could very well be that
neither the best effort
um
case nor the random sampling right here
have really hit sort of the tasks to
include and there might actually be a
subset that is even better but it's kind
of unlikely
um they they've done a different thing
where they
compare
pre-training versus pre-fine tuning so
pre-training is
i try i train
on the supervised tasks and on language
modeling all at the same time and then i
fine-tune once on my target task
and pre-fine tuning is i first do sort
of pre-training
in fact they start with a standard t5
based checkpoint and then
after that concluded they what they call
pre-fine-tune so essentially it is
another step of pre-training but
starting from a checkpoint they pre-fine
tune with this ex mix data set
and after this phase we fine tune on
super glue so to compare
the comparison is simply that you have
like a pre-training
and then you have a
pre-fine tuning which is where the this
ex mix
data set goes in
and then you have
a fine tuning
and an eval
on the same data set
and they compare the setting where you
do the three
in stages right here
compared to when you do these two things
at the same time
and then you fine tune and evaluate okay
the bottom row is sort of the baseline
and the top row is what they actually
suggest
what they suggest is that hey we should
just do all the pre-training at the same
time on the supervised tasks on the on
the self-supervised tasks and so on
so here you can see if you simply take
vanilla model fine-tune it on superglue
you get a 76.1 i'm gonna guess that's
the t5 base checkpoint right here then
if you pre-fine-tune that checkpoint on
ex mix you do get 78.1 on superglue
which is a considerable considerable
increase right
however if you
simply do the same but include that
those that ex mixed data sets into the
pre-training you do get an even bigger
boost so how do we make
sense of that uh that is it that is a
good question
um
i'm not entirely
sure but maybe a hypothesis or so i've
in the comments but one hypothesis here
is that i have is that
a supervised nlp data set you know if
you if you look at these tasks right
here
what does it really mean to be a
supervised nlp data set
what it means is that
by
determining a label to a prompt you sort
of as a labeler bring in
additional knowledge that is not just in
the text right so
you know in order for you to parse this
kind of funkle query
you have to
know a bunch of things so give me a list
of airlines in pittsburgh you can see
right here okay pittsburgh
there is like city name okay so you need
to recognize this is a city this is
already information that you kind of
bring in
into the model that just goes beyond
language modeling right
services so the recognition that an
airline is servicing a city
that is again it's kind of real world
knowledge so i think that you know if
you compare
having these tasks here versus having
just self-supervised pre-training it is
a bit deceitful that you say well we
train on the same amount of tokens or we
train for the same amount of steps
because i think the labeled examples are
much more information dense because they
sort of bring in
knowledge that is not in the tokens
themselves but kind of in just
like in the
in the
positioning of the label
with prompt you bring in additional
knowledge that you know
it's not the same as simply a piece of
text with that many tokens
that is one
of the observations that i for myself
could make
right here why this is quite helpful
so it conveys world knowledge or it
conveys grammar knowledge or whatnot to
the model
by
these by means of these labeled data
sets
the second thing is that
um
i do think we have a lot of evidence
that especially the beginning of neural
network training are quite important so
you never
in a neural network you never quite get
rid of your pre-training
so i think that explains this right here
we know that if you pre-train it doesn't
matter how many steps of fine tuning and
fine fine tuning and fine fine
fine-tuning you have
the pre-training especially the one at
the very beginning will always be
somewhat represented in that model it
will always influence a model quite a
bit how you exactly pre-train
or on what
it's almost like
it's almost like you you have kind of
like endless possibilities to go as a
model from your initialization right and
then once once you've picked one you
know once you've picked one of these
directions
all you can really do is kind of find
you know find wiggle your way into
better
local optima but they're all essentially
in the same conceptual area like in the
same direction right here and if you
were to start with a different data set
you might choose a very different
direction at the beginning one much more
amenable to the kind of
natural language inference prompts that
you're going to do
that is just that is like a hypothesis
that could be right and that would kind
of explain why pre-fine tuning works
less
well than simply pre-training from the
get-go on the multiple tasks
so what do we learn initialization or
early stages of training might be quite
important especially for like generative
models like like these
um they go further and they ask
themselves you know since i've
i've shown you that they have
in addition to all the supervised tasks
they have this top row right here which
is this self-supervised task that you're
used to from language model it's
formulated a bit differently with the
prompt input and the prompt output but
essentially this is masked language
modeling like you'd you'd encounter in
like bert
in the form of auto regressive language
modeling as you would encounter it in a
in a gpt model
so
the question is of course you have
two data sets so even if you somehow
managed of these 107 data sets to get
roughly like equal data for each one how
should you mix the self-supervised
objective with the supervised objective
and
the answer is you should
somewhat mix them
and uh how much that's that's detailed
in the plot here
so
you can see right here r is the ratio of
self-supervised to supervised um
pre-training data and then the y-axis is
the performance when fine-tuned on super
glue
now to the if you go to the right you
can see that the blue line approaches
the dashed line and the dashed line is
simply the performance without any
supervised data at all so if you simply
pre-train on the masked language
modeling and then you fine tune on super
glue it makes sense as r goes to
infinity that the proportion of
supervised data approaches zero
so that blue line must meet the dashed
line however it's pretty interesting
what happens at the beginning note that
if r is zero the performance is terrible
that means if you only have like
supervised tasks
that is crap that is just not good at
all and i think this this might even be
like this i think this is a super
important recognition you know for all
the well you need a lot of tasks and so
on if you don't have your language model
pre-training if you don't have yourself
supervised pre-training even if you have
the same amount of data points it is
going to be crap right so there is
something for
having these self-supervised
tasks right here and and having them all
actually learn this
like grammar and continuing just bland
pieces of text that are not geared
towards some specific task
because you know
if you then have to pick up on new tasks
it kind of helps you that you've just
been around language it seems
and that's this is also a hypothesis is
that
these supervised data sets by means of
all being on the same task right every
one of these 107 data sets contains data
points that is like structured exactly
the same the amount of world knowledge
in there is quite big yet the amount of
language knowledge in there is quite
small right um
all like all the
all the fungal all the fungal data set
um prompts are gonna look
not only are they all gonna start with
like parse two funkle colon but they're
gonna kind of look the same like they're
gonna be like the sentence they're gonna
be very much the same
uh the the answers are going to be well
they're not even text but also they're
all like very much the same you're not
going to get random text in such a query
you're going to get text
you know for the for the entities it
knows and for the kinds of facts that it
wants to express
uh so the supervised data sets while
being good
in having labels they're quite bad at
actually expressing language which is
is interesting right um
because
it is something that is especially
pronounced in language i feel because if
we for example look at images
would it
i guess i guess it might hurt too if we
if we had like imagenet but so if we had
like a huge huge image net
um maybe it's still hurt because it's
only like the thousand classes and
images 10 like imagenet images that are
made for classification tend to like
display
one particular object in the middle
yeah i don't know
but in language certainly like nlp tasks
they have
super limited language
so
it's important
towards here we approach obviously the
performance without supervised data if
we don't have any self-supervised data
it just does not work or it just works
very poorly however there is an
interesting regime right here as you can
see as soon as we hit one which means
equal amount of
self-supervised and supervised data
um
we our performance improves over just
using self-supervised data and then if
the ratio is two that seems to work
quite well as you can see right here
that is almost 80 that is that's quite a
big jump in super glue performance
however
as we know if our grows this must come
down again it comes down quick pretty
quickly already at four it seems to be
almost back to where it started and then
kind of wobbling around uh or or so it
seems of these experiments are big so
you can't exactly fault the authors for
not
uh evaluating
many times and giving error bars though
here in this case it would have been
quite nice
um
so you can see the window is quite
narrow and that is a little bit of a
disappointment by me or a bit of a
criticism here is that
yes it's good that you can get something
if you have this many pre-training tasks
and so on but in a real world scenario
right um you know i don't
i don't know
how many how much i need of that right i
could go with a good guess and
say well probably other data sets have
similar behaviors as super glue but you
know who knows and generally if windows
are so small for hyper parameters it's a
bit of a risk
and if in practice i always have to do
giant experiments to
evaluate whether that hyperparameter
setting is still appropriate and it's
not really a gain because
like it doesn't save me anything because
i always have to do this evaluation
but maybe you know maybe this turns out
to be fairly robust
this number two
who knows
in their experiments at least they did
then they go on and they
ask
okay so we got 107 tasks if we simply
pick random subsets of these tasks how
does that impact performance as you can
see there is a trendy trendish thing
sort of upwards
there is a bit of a downwards here but
nobody knows because as you can see here
we do kind of have error bars and
they're
kind of big the standard deviations
um what you can also see is that for
larger batch sizes the trend seems to be
kind of more consistent and better uh
we've known for a while that larger
batch sizes help these things but i
guess especially if you have so many
different tasks together having a big
batch size means that it's much more
probable that you have sort of balanced
data that you don't end up with a batch
with only data from one particular task
which kind of wanks all the other
weights out of out of whack or if you
have like two or three batches uh one
after another of these it can be quite
detrimental
so
that is maybe one but yeah that like the
standard deviations are quite big as you
can see but clearly the higher batch
size is better even if they have like
the same same compute budget right so
it's not like
the higher batch size experiment uh
like saw more data at least i don't
think so or or had more compute
and the last thing is they compare
when they compare during training so
they ask themselves which is this really
sample efficient and the answer is
compared to like a t5 model yes it's
quite it's quite sample efficient um as
you can see right here
comparing these two models
you can see that even after the same
compute amount of compute after the same
amount of steps the ex t5 model is quite
a bit higher than the t5 model so it's
not just at the end it's in fact
during all of training so you could
potentially stop earlier and get like
the same performance as the t5 model
would get much later in the training
so for example this point here is
already reached here way earlier of
course the longer you go out the the
more extreme this effect gets
and that's basically it for the ablation
experiments this is the part of the
paper that i i quite liked because it's
kind of investigative and it sort of
justifies
um their their
choices
and the choices are pretty simple right
it's just like throw everything in there
and do everything at the same time but
instead of just doing it and then
evaluating which they do down here
obviously they're kind of
better at most things
um
in in distribution tasks out of
distribution tasks yada yada uh
yeah like
they're just they're better like trust
me though it is it is interesting to see
that very often they're not that much
better like they're kind of like all
right t5 gets like
29.01 and you get like
29.49 like who knows how big of a
difference this is it it is i guess for
a machine translation that is a
difference
still it's not that much honestly on
other tasks you can see right here uh
the t5
uh gets what is this 55 and this is 63
this is quite a big difference
i think i saw other tables where the
differences were
even more drastically so it
seems to really depend on the task as
well whether or not this can get you a
gain or not
um
yeah so i quite liked
i quite liked this investigation into
are we doing the right thing even even
though
what they want to do is is the most
simple thing is just like throw
everything together into one giant model
and add some self-supervised as well at
the same time
but yeah it is interesting to see
and
if you want to learn more and dig into
their exact results right here this is
all available in the appendix there is a
split of exactly how the 107 tasks are
if i understand correctly here you can
see the different data sets used to
construct ex mix
implementation details and so on it is
it is quite thorough um
yeah
so that was it for
ext5 in summary this is a t5 model that
has been supercharged by pre-training it
on a combined language modeling
objective and
a
supervised objective that is a mixture
of 107 different nlp tasks all at the
same time in a ratio of
two parts of self-supervised and one
part of supervised data and that turns
out to perform extremely well if you
fine tune it on downstream task and in
fact it's not really
easily possible to outdo that recipe by
doing something smarter out of the box
so by
selecting a good subset of tasks or by
um
or
what was my my point ready or by somehow
staggering the things like doing this
like first the pre-training and then the
pre-fine tuning and so on uh it's not
easy to beat it
that was my point my my two cents on
this paper if
you enjoyed it leave a like if you
didn't enjoy it i guess you can leave a
dislike but you know what's he gonna do
honestly uh youtube i'll i still see it
right i still see how many dislikes i
got but
uh if you dislike the video tell me in a
comment what you disliked
alright i'll see you next time bye